Hey everyone. Welcome to AIM 396,
where we're gonna talk about how to integrate, uh,
open source, uh, frameworks
with Amazon Bedrock Asian Core.
Uh, my name is Shreya Subramanyan. I'm a
principal data scientist at AWS.
I also have Ari,
who's a senior GEI specialist SA at AWS,
and we're happy to also share the stage
with, uh, Keith, who's a VP of Engineering at Coher
Health. So
before we get started, uh, quick show
of hands, how many of you have, uh,
built an agent with either a no code
tool or low code or, or an open source
framework?
Quite, quite a lot of us, yeah, and so you might recognize
some of the frameworks up here and also the protocols.
So building a basic agent requires piecing
together all these different complex components,
right? So you have, uh, picking a framework,
picking what tools to integrate with, you also
have, uh, state management,
but fortunately. Some of these open source frameworks
came first and it really simplifies the way
you can build these agents.
Uh, we also have open protocols like NCP
and A2A that, uh,
that help with connecting agents to agents or agents
or tools.
We have open protocols and standards like
OA for, uh, authorization.
We have Otel for observability, and all of
these help you
start off really quickly and build a POC.
But going from POC to production is
a totally different
ball game, right?
So at AWS
since its inception we've been contributing to open
source and we're proud to do that.
Uh, we think open source is good for everyone.
Uh, we've been, uh, you know, contributing to
Linux Foundation, the open source
projects on GitHub,
uh, both, uh, you know, we're, we're in the,
um, Asians related talks, so
we thought we contribute to strands, which
is our own.
Uh, Asiantic framework with, uh, and also with
other open source frameworks we believe open
source is good for everyone. We're committed to bringing this,
uh, via managed services to
our customers and you'll hear from,
uh, Keith at Goher Health and, uh, uh,
on more about this as well.
So today we'll be talking about specifically
how Asian Core works with open
source frameworks. If you haven't been
in other Asian Core sessions, so
Asian Core is our end to end Asian
tech platform that helps you build and operate
agents at scale.
Um, and so zooming
out, you know, a 30,000 ft view of,
uh, Asian core, if you look at all of these components
that you see on your screen.
Uh, we,
uh, Asian core is comprised of all of these individual
services. You can pick and choose what you want.
Uh, in the center of your screen is, uh,
Asian core runtime.
So with runtime, you can deploy any open
source agent as well as MCP servers
and A2A servers, uh, with
no changes in code or minimal changes in
code. Um, these runtime
agents, uh, run in a session
isolated environment.
Uh, it can be a back and forth, um,
agent where you have a conversational, uh,
interface or you have a long-running agent
that can run for hours and hours, like a deep research
agent, right?
Um, runtime also integrates with all
of these other agent core services.
So for example, runtime integrates with identity,
which is our,
uh, agent,
uh, identity and credential management
service. It also integrates with memory, which
is, um,
the first, uh, one of the first, uh, enterprise
grade memory capabilities that you can have
zero infrastructure set up, but you have short-term
and long-term memory, uh, that can attach
to your agents,
um. We also recently introduced
policy and evals in Asian core,
so this helps you constrain and also
judge how well your agents are doing in in in production.
Um, what connects all of these
different services together is, uh,
observability or Asian Core Observatory, which
works on the open telemetry
or hotel format.
The nice thing with Agent Core, as I said, was
you can pick and choose
whatever services you want and, uh, to
build your, you know, Asiane application.
And uh today we'll see uh
different flavors of observability, for example, so
Keith, uh Keith will talk about arrays and
how they use that in production. Ari will talk
about how uh we can use lang fuse
with uh, with Asian core as well.
So before we get into
uh the details, let's start with a really basic
scenario, right?
So let's say you have uh your customers, you
wanna, uh,
uh, you wanna track an order and you're,
you're usually contacting customer service
and this uh customer service representative
might have to uh look into
like order management system or external shipping
provider API or maybe even call
them to get, get order status, right?
Uh, they might also have to work with other technical,
uh, support, uh, you know, human
resources, so you have two teams
working together to actually get your final answer,
uh, which a lot of times is have you start
try restarting it. So, uh, you know, after
all of that effort you might get back an answer
in a couple of days.
We're gonna try and replace these,
uh, two humans, uh, or human
resources teams out there with, uh,
agents, right? So you have a customer service agent.
And a technical support agent. Now these agents
may not replace the entire
functionality of the jobs to be done of, of,
uh, these persons. Uh, it might
just have to do a partial job or might be a
co-pilot that's domain specific
as well. So
how do you get started? The first gut reaction
we have is to look into open source frameworks
because open source frameworks have,
you know, deep and, uh, wide integrations
and community support, and, uh, we have great
examples that you can start off with, right? So our gut reaction
is usually there,
but how do you pick which framework you have to start
with? Uh, there are a lot of different
factors including how your team is,
uh, working with certain,
uh, frameworks already,
but, uh, we're listing three top,
uh, you know, frameworks in our minor list, so
Landgraf, crew AI, and strands agents,
and, uh, we're just listing a few factors that you can
choose, uh, your agent tech frameworks
with. Uh, so Landgraf offers a graph-based
execution with extensive open
source, uh, integrations.
So it's powerful, but then it has a really steep,
uh, learning curve compared to some of the other frameworks.
So it is, it's still good for complex
agent orchestration, uh, with strong
community support.
Uh, crew AI, on the other hand is really easy
to get started with and especially for role-based
and team-based agents where you're, you're running
a multi-agent crew,
uh, this is the best place to start
with, uh, strands, which is our
own open source agenttic framework. Uh,
you, you provide, uh, we provide like a model-based
approach and, uh. Has
access to local as well as Asian core memory,
for example, and this is ideal for a
starting point for uh enterprise grade enttic
applications that are running on AWS, right?
So you have all of these choices. You might have many more
we in fact have many applications and,
uh, and, uh, use cases that we have put
in our GitHub repository they can check out.
Uh, but the good thing is you can pick and choose,
uh, the frameworks for, uh, the
right job, right? So you, in this case we're
picking strands for the customer service agent
and, uh, land graph for the technical support
agent.
You don't have to choose two different frameworks. You can choose the
same framework as well,
but in, in this case, as an example, we're saying,
uh, where you're choosing strands for customer support and Land
graph for technical support.
So what's the best way to get started
with that, right? So you have, let's say, a
strands customer support agent that's running locally
on your laptop. You have, uh, local credentials
in there. Uh, the credentials let you
access APIs that are hosted in AWS,
and, uh, these A AWS APIs,
you know, you can access because you have local credentials.
Uh, the technical support agent, uh,
you're, you're doing some hard, uh, integration
between the stand support, uh, agent and technical
support agent.
And uh what you also see is that the customer
support agent has an API key that may
that may integrate with an external service provider.
Uh, but you can quickly notice that this is
not gonna scale, right? So this is running on your laptop.
It's not something that you can, you can host
and you can have multiple users interact
with. But your goal is to, you know, put
this out for, you know, tens of thousands of users
to use. So how do you do that?
That's where agent core runtime comes in, and
we spoke about Acore runtime a little bit. This
is where, uh, you know, we mentioned line graph
strands and other agenttic frameworks. You can very easily
host these, uh,
these agents, and you get a dedicated endpoint.
These endpoints scale automatically based on
your, uh, requests, and you can,
uh, go from zero to production really quickly,
right? Uh, you can also connect
these agents to any model provider, so it doesn't
have to be Bedrock. It can be OpenAI. It could be any
model provider pretty much,
and, uh, you can also work with really strict
security guidelines, so it could be a VPC only
mode or you can only use OA.
Uh, we also introduced, uh, resource-based
access policies recently.
Uh, today we also launched full support
for the MCP spec. So if you have an MCP server,
you can, uh, you can go and host the MCP
server without any change in code.
Uh, also, bi-directional streaming was launched recently,
which is useful for something like our customer service,
uh, agent, right? So you're doing right now
imagine a text-based interface, but imagine you wanna
convert that to a voice-based interface. You can
very easily do that with runtime because runtime
now supports bi-directional streaming.
All right. So how do you actually,
you know, host these two agents we said there's a
customer support agent and this Land graph agent.
How do you host that on runtime?
Uh, there's two main methods to do that. You can either
package up your code in the, in a docker container.
That Docker container gets pushed to an ECR repository,
and that ECR repository can be used as,
uh, the starting point for deploying to runtime.
Uh, the other even easier way is you
can zip up your, uh, deployments in a,
in a zip file,
and, uh, you can push that to S3 bucket, and then
that S3 bucket becomes a starting point for
your deployments and run. So it's 22 different
methods,
uh, and to do this you have to actually
make a few lines of, uh, code
change, right? And this basically says,
um,
you know, make the right imports from the Bedrock Asian core
SDK, uh, initialize this
app which is actually a star app.
Um, and, um, and then
you have a decorator. It's easy decorator at
app. entry point just points to this
handler or this entry point as the starting point
for your agent execution.
What happens inside that my agent function
that you see, it's completely up to you
to be any agent, any framework that you're integrating
with, any business logic,
uh, and then finally you return a response.
What do you expect to work is,
um, you know, whether it's sync or as sync
responses or if it's streaming responses, all of
those should work,
you know, as though it was running locally.
And this will with runtime, right?
So now that you've made those little changes in your code,
the next step is actually to use our Bedrock
Asian code starter toolkit.
This is a really simple way to go from,
uh, you know, a, a code that exists locally
to a code that can, can be deployed. You
have 3 steps.
The first step is to agent is to do Asian
core configure.
So Asian core configure will basically set
up your things like ECR repository that you
want to land in, uh, your role, uh,
whether you want IAM or OA,
uh, all of that just sits in a config file that's
local. You can go back in and edit it on your own
as well, but easy to manage
it with Asian core.
Uh, the Asian Corres CLI also has this
next step which is deploy. So you can do Asian core
deploy, which will deploy to
run time depending on those two choices that if
you recall from the previous slide, so you have either the container
version or the zip deployment version.
And finally, you know,
within a minute it'll be deployed and you can start invoking
your agent.
All of the scaling and infrastructure management, all
of that is, you know, happily managed behind
the scenes, and you don't have to worry about it.
Once you've, uh, launched that agent, of course,
you can start invoking it. And in this
case, we're saying, OK, we're gonna use two different
runtimes,
one for the sciences agent, one for the Landgraf
agent. Uh, there are use cases
where you want both to coexist, but in this
case, we're saying you can have, you know, two different containers
that are running up for you.
Um,
everything else remains the same, meaning the Asian
core runtime has an execution role. It
lets you access AWS, uh, APIs.
Um, it also, you can use identity
to store, uh, secret credentials, and
that can be an API key, for example, for your
external shipping provider if you wanna
track a shipment through that API, for example,
um, but if you notice the integration
between these, um,
containers and the API as well as
from the one container to another container something that you
manage, right? So.
Um,
before we dive in even deeper there,
let's talk about context engineering for agents.
This is, uh, you know, you might have heard about context
engineering and prompt engineering earlier,
uh, but when applied to agent, if we zoom
out, zoom into one of those agents, so either the strands
one or the land graph one.
Uh, we can see that the context that you
provide to that agent is extremely important, right?
So you can have user instructions, you can have,
um, you know, system instructions, you
have retrieved information from rag systems, for
example, uh, you might have short-term memory
coming in with previous conversations, and you might
have external or internal tools that are giving
you additional context.
So imagine if your tool uh gives
you, you know, uh, a wrong context
or a wrong response,
uh, or worse, if you call the wrong tool, the
LLM calls the wrong tool on your, on your behalf.
That still remains in your context for the
agent and your agent is gonna respond based on
that. So how can we, how can
we make sure that all of this, uh, is
handled, but we don't have to actually handle
the integration points, right?
So you as a developer are, are
basically responsible for connecting those
different nodes, right? So you have the customer service agent
which is strands, uh, you're writing integration
code to connect to your order management system,
writing separate integration code to do an API
call. Um, and then when you're
connecting from one agent to another agent, you're also writing
another integration code. So quickly,
your integration code becomes the bulk load
of your entire code base, right? You're
not focusing on your business logic, but it's all of this integration
code. But what if you
could use some of these open protocols to
help you out there?
So one of the things that you've already probably heard about is
MCP. MCP allows you to
securely access external data and
tools through a common interface.
Um,
so there are two connection points to, you know, MCP
within, uh, Asian core. One, if
you host your own MCP servers or you
have the code for your MCP servers, you can
host that on runtime with no changes in code
and literally no changes in code.
Uh, if you have external APIs or
Smithy models that connect to internal AWS,
uh, tools, or even API gateway
setup that you want to connect and MCP file.
You can use Gateway for that. So Asian Core Gateway
helps you
create an MCP interface to all of your
existing APIs. So there's two ways you can
take Asian core components and then connect
it back to MCP.
So that's from your agent to tools, right?
So what about agent to agent? So as, as
the name suggests, A2A is
standard, standardizing the interface when you want agents
to talk to each other, right? So it was originally developed
by uh Google,
but then it was uh donated to the Linux Foundation
soon after.
Uh, so agents may be built
with different frameworks, different languages, different
models, and might be coming in from different
providers as well.
Uh, but you still want them to talk to each other, uh,
you know, natively.
And so on the right we're just showing an example
of uh
three different agents talking to each other with uh
with uh 82A
since 82A is a native protocol
like MCP that's supported in runtime. Once
again you don't have to,
don't have to do any changes in code and you can
directly host your 82A servers.
Uh, you can have an 82A client similar to
an MCP client connect to these 82A
servers to test it out as well.
So great. So now we're gonna change that little architecture
diagon a little bit.
So you have a customer service agent
that's connected through the blue line, which is A2A
to another uh Landgraf's technical
support agent. The red lines are now MCP,
so that's a standard interface to go from
the strands agent to an auto management API,
which is, by the way, an internal AWS
setup that you have. It also has another connection
to an external shipping provider API.
So gateway, for example, if you have an open
API spec for your internal, uh, for
your external shipping provider API, you can import
that into
an MCP, um, MCP gateway.
Uh, what we also have is deeper
open source integrations into,
uh, some of these agent core components from
the frameworks itself.
So we're constantly, you know, uh, pumping back
some of this
development back into the open source frameworks.
One of the things that you can do, you can, you can have the
stands, uh,
a customer service agent
use the built-in session manager, and
you can add agent core memory to it. So both short-term
memory, which is STM on the slide there, and
then long term memory as well.
Um, similarly, in, in Landgraph,
we have some deep integrations as well. So you
can use, uh, what's called Asian core memory
Saver, and what that does is you can save
and load your checkpoints, and checkpoints
store information like your user AI
conversation or your graph execution state, and
that can be,
you know, loaded onto memory, and then once
you restart your applications your gentic container,
you can rehydrate the container and restart where you
left off. So
we're excited to continue our partnership
with, you know, Landgraf and Langchain and, uh,
all of us, you know,
our examples are based on some of these open
source frameworks.
Uh, for Landgraph specifically, we
do this via the Lang chain AWS library,
so you can pip install lang chain AWS.
This gives you all of the, you know, AWS Landgraph
superpowers,
uh, like the one we saw earlier for the, for
the memory checkpointing, for example.
Um, with strands, of course this is
our own homegrown, uh,
agent SDK,
but it also has 4000 stars and
a million downloads, and it's growing,
uh, you know,
definitely check it out if you haven't already. It's
easy to get started with and we have a bunch of
examples.
Uh, we are the primary maintainers of strands, but
then it's a completely open source project.
Um, lastly, the way we
collaborate with some other frameworks like Crew AI
is that we help make direct contributions
to their, um, to their repositories
themselves. So Aris actually has a blog up
there, uh,
uh, where you can scan and take a look at that. It's
to build Asian systems with Crew AI and, and
Amazon Bedrock,
uh, separately, I helped Lama Index, you know,
uh, with their RAG implementations and
also integrations into Asian core.
So we're happily continuing to do this,
um, over and over again. So let's get back
to our. Application at the end.
So now you have,
um,
uh, you know, agent core runtime that
is used to run your customer service agent
and your Landgraf technical support agent.
Um, you have, um,
A2A being the interface between those two agents,
right? Uh, then you have, uh,
memory resources that are attached to each agent.
There's also another alternative. You could have the
two agents have a common memory resource as well if
that's, that's the way an application is set up,
but in this case, imagine you have two separate
memory resources for uh this,
the customer support agent and the uh technical
support agent, and then finally you have a gateway
that connects to the external tools as well.
With that, we'll have Iris come up and, uh,
talk about
how engineering teams are transitioning from traditional
DevOps to what we're calling agent ops,
Iris. Thanks,
Treyus. So, now that we have
learned how we can build powerful agents
with
AWS services like Agent Core and
the Open Source.
And about the powerful integrations between these
two, we wanna take it one step further and think
about how we can put that into production
with operational excellence, obviously, right?
So in the next 20 minutes, I wanna talk about
uh uh a couple of
things that we have worked on in, in the last
months, together with some major players in the open
source space uh here as well.
And um I wanna start with
uh
operational excellence. If you think about operational
excellence in traditional software engineering,
probably everyone would say DevOps is really a thing here,
right? And we would probably also
agree that DevOps is not one dimensional.
DevOps has a lot of different dimensions
that we really wanna get right if
we wanna be good in, in, in that field.
Starting from infrastructure, we need to manage
our infrastructure from top to the
bottom. We need to pick the right tools with
a lot of automation.
And then we are all people, we are an engineering
community,
and we work in processes embracing
a specific culture.
Now, in the first days of DevOps,
all of these things were really not easy because
we didn't have, we had a cloud, but we didn't
have a lot of managed services, right?
We didn't have that set of comprehensive
tooling that we have today,
and we hadn't yet agreed on a new
common culture. A lot of the things were still very
waterfall-like, um,
so engineers really had a hard time.
But, and we at AWS have pioneered
that in, in the last decade, um, you
know, a lot of organizations out there
and also the open source space
have been inventing a lot of cool things over
the past 1015 years here, right?
So we at AWS we launched powerful services
like Lambda, like EKS, like S3.
Like CloudWatch, many more services
that make all of our lives easier.
We have entire companies that have raced out of
the open source space. If you think about GitHub
or Docker.
And then we all as a community have embraced
a new way of doing software engineering
that is super agile with a lot of
automation
with
CICD
which is actually benefiting us uh
a lot, right? So what I wanna talk about
today is how can we take what's working well
in traditional software engineering.
And kind of evolve it into uh
the agentic era that is starting now
with all the new functional and non-functional
requirements um that are
arising.
And I wanna do that sequentially, one
pillar after the other before bringing it
together at the end.
Starting with infrastructure, as I
said, we have been pioneering that field,
um, for traditional software engineering
with services like Lambda, S3,
and many more.
And we haven't started reinventing
on your behalf. Um,
Shreas has mentioned a service that we have launched
in July at New York Summit.
Agent Core really specialized, uh,
for agentic workloads.
I'm not gonna spend a lot of time, uh, once
again, you have heard a lot from Shreyas. You have heard probably
a lot about this service in the past days,
but
It is really
absolutely useful in this specific scenario
because it is a civil service. It
spins up agents quickly.
There's a lot of things that the service is
basically managing uh for you, so
we strongly recommend uh recommend using
a service like Agent Core um and you will
see how you benefit from it down the line
as we go through the other pillars sequentially.
Moving on to tools, um,
tools is actually a pretty vibrant
space or has been a pretty vibrant space in the last
1 to 3 years.
A lot of stuff that, um, you know,
organizations have built, we have built a lot of tooling,
uh, within Bedrock, but also is Agent
Core if you think about,
um, observability, the, the primitive
or evaluations that we have launched here at Reinvent.
But also the open source space and the startup
space was pretty vibrant, so I
was working with a lot of those startups
across, uh, or alongside the last 1-2
years.
The wide combinator cohorts were full of those,
um, and, uh, you know, a lot of
great tooling has been popping up.
Since this is kind of an ecosystem open source session,
we're gonna focus on that space uh today
and um as Treas has already
said, um, I'm gonna focus on Langfuse,
which is one of the largest open source uh
uh providers for observability
for, um, you know, agent ops
um as well.
I've been collaborating strongly with those folks
in the last months to develop the approach
that we're gonna be presenting, um, but
again. Whether proprietary
or open source, you can really pick and choose
because everything is built upon open standards.
And if you think about open standards, observability.
Operations,
DevOps, agent ops,
really one of the most important here um
is open telemetry.
What is open telemetry? It's not a new
thing. It's been around for years in traditional
software engineering.
Um,
but what we have done as community is really we
have further developed it, um, again
to like work with
the new arising functional and non-functional
requirements.
It defines a set of semantic conventions,
uh, which you can see here on the right side.
So we basically standardize how we are capturing,
um,
the data points, the telemetry
in objects.
And then we have also standardized, um,
the way how we actually
You know, collect them and ship them into
so-called open telemetry back ends.
So the way that works is we all use
these open source frameworks. They are auto instrumented.
That means there is already code in there that is
collecting those metrics automatically for you
if you configure them right.
There is standardized exporters
that are being built by
organizations or by the open source which are exporting
that data,
streaming them to the back ends, and these back
ends. Can be the platforms we have
talked about. So our, um, you know, observability
platform that is tightly integrated with,
with, uh, with CloudWatch,
um, or a third party
open source ones like Langfuse.
Now, I want to spend a minute
speaking about Langfuse to really make sure
we are all on the same page. Um,
what is Langfuse? Uh, it's an open
source LLM engineering platform
uh that is one of those open telemetry back
ends. Um,
this means you can stream your traces.
Your telemetry there is being stored,
and then, uh, on top of that,
there's a rich set of features that
that you can leverage. So you have core observability.
Um, where you can actually
look into in a visual way what's, what's really
happening in your agents.
And then there is a lot of other features as well, like
prompt and data set management,
EAs, experiments, um,
human annotation cues, uh, many more
things,
and we're gonna use a couple of those, uh, further
down the line.
So to come back to the solution architecture that
Rees has been building up um sequentially
in the session, um,
you might recognize we have removed a couple of
components that are not necessarily
crucial for agent ops,
but what what we really wanna do is we wanna um
use length fuse, so we need to host it.
It comes, it's open source under MIT license,
so you can just host it in your AWS account
if you want.
There's a marketplace offering where you choose
uh the fully managed SARS
version of Langfuse called Langfuse Cloud.
And this is also the one
that you will find being used in
the code repository we're going to share at the end of
this session.
Now you see two black lines here
uh connecting agent core runtime,
um, and, and, and length fuse basically.
Um, I wanna focus on the top one,
because this is really the last thing we need
to do before we are up running, up and running.
We need to actually configure
how, how the streaming of the traces
works at the end. Um,
it's not difficult, but it's just a couple
of things we need to configure.
We need to set a couple of, or we need
to configure a couple of settings, like for
example, which endpoint we're gonna stream our telemetry
to, um,
and things like how we're gonna authenticate
against length use.
Um, a good way to do that is through setting
environment variables. When we are deploying the agents
in Agent core, you can see that on the right side.
And then on the left side, um, uh,
you know, this is basically a boilerplate
agent implementation and strengths
for agent core
you will, uh, you know, uh,
recognize a couple of things that Treas has
shared before.
All we really need to do is, uh, adding
two lines of code. I unfortunately don't
have a pointer here right now, but it's two lines
of code where you are initializing an exporter.
And this will, uh,
you know, pull the environment variables in
and then the configuration is being
set up and you will see traces
flowing into length fuse as you're using your
agents.
And this is how it looks like you have
a rich set of information like the time stamps,
the input and output of your agent on a high
level. You can see how many observation
levels um the agent was going
through, so how many turns it was doing till it
solved the problem,
talking counts, latency,
like a lot of information, and then you can also
zoom into the different traces.
With the observation levels on the top left again,
we have a graph execution view can be
useful for us humans, a visual way to
see complex
executions.
And on the right side you see,
you know, the data points we have collected
in the trace
based on the semantic convention we have defined.
All right, so now we've connected
infrastructure and tooling, uh, we know
what's going on.
The next question is obviously how can we build
processes around that,
that are leveraging this, that
are kind of making our life easier
towards production.
And
we were actually thinking a lot about
what
would be a good approach to start together with
the lengthiest folks and.
Uh, we started working backwards
from, from DevOps, right? So we were thinking
about what is working good in DevOps,
um, and how can we evolve it. And the first thing
we actually realized was
a crucial concept in DevOps is testing.
DevOps doesn't work without testing.
And the analogy,
even though it's a bit more complicated
to testing in in Gen AI and agents
is evaluation.
So we were thinking about um
how does evaluation play a crucial role
alongside the entire life cycle of energetic
application. And we found a pretty cool illustration
from from evidently.
That is actually showcasing that. And
uh
we, we usually start kind of in a, in a, in a mode
where we are
trying to figure out a good implementation.
So we are changing the code, maybe different frameworks,
different models, prompts, sets of tools.
And we want to figure out what works best, so
we are running experiments based on
some data sets that we have put together
and we are running EVAs on top of that. It is an
iterative process,
and at some point
we come to or
at some point we basically have a state
that is
as we think, good enough to deploy into production.
We deploy the production, we collect the traces,
as we have seen earlier on,
and then we enter a kind of a phase of
where we are thriving towards,
first of all, operational excellence.
By
moving into a more online way of
running EVOs,
building dashboards, creating automated alerts,
for example, right?
So this is operational excellence.
We want our stuff to be running well.
But then we also want to close the loop. We want to
learn from what's happening in production, which means
we can feedback learnings
from production into our test data sets.
If we realize that the
data set distribution is not matching
the distribution in production in reality,
but we can also get inspired by what's happening
in production.
To
implement new things, right, so whether
this is fixing bugs, fixing
issues, or just the next best feature.
All right, so the next step was really, um,
we were thinking about, um, this is a great
theoretical framework, but how can we make that
a bit more tangible,
a sequential process, uh, that we can
start also then, uh, uh, or that, that
can get,
that we can also implement later on, right?
And uh what we came up with, with, was
this uh three-stage approach. We
start with an experimentation HPO
phase where we wanna try out what's working
well. Then we move further
towards production where we have
guard rails to production. Basically,
we wanna, we wanna really make sure that everything is
working. So we have a QA
and testing phase and uh we
wanna automate that, we wanna do that
with CICD because that's working really well
in DevOps as well.
And then we go into production,
operational excellence, learning from working what's in
production and closing the loop.
Now,
a lot of theory,
going a bit more practical, uh, again,
um, one step deeper,
uh, we have talked about, you know, the process,
the culture that we, that we wanna evolve now. I wanna
come back to the infrastructure and tooling
pillar to speak about how we can actually implement
that. I want to start with infrastructure,
then go over to tooling, but before I
do that, um, we have two core assumptions
that we are building all of that up on.
And the first assumption is
really
that we strongly recommend
to use a multi-environment setup.
Different staging environments, dev, test,
prod. It really makes
sense. You don't want to experiment in your
production environment and break the back end of your
production application.
Probably a lot of you have already implemented
that. If not, we are strongly recommending
it. And the second thing
is maybe a controversial one for
developers, but we strongly recommend end
to end remote cloud-based
development, especially when we have surveless
services at hand.
I know a lot of people like to develop locally,
to get started for a POC locally, notebooks
maybe,
and this is great, but as you mature in
your work, as you have like a lot of teams
doing that, a lot of use cases,
you reach a point where it actually it doesn't scale
anymore. You have
MCP tools that are remote that
you're not owning, which you might
not be able to access.
And you really don't want your developers to
spend weeks of development work
uh just to realize that the
stuff they have built is working on their local machine, but
not in the target environment.
So with those assumptions, uh,
moving further, um, uh,
and getting started, uh, to the implementation.
So first phase, uh, experimentation, um,
HPO we wanna figure out what's working well
alongside a set of hyperparameters
or implementations.
But we don't want to do that by rule of thumb,
just trying
a couple of things out
and seeing what works. We want to have solid data
points. We want to have a proven methodology.
Um,
so what we can do is actually, and
automation concepts like infrastructure is
code, um, but also
the cloud, the fact that you can spin up agents
in a matter of seconds with agent core comes really
handy here is
you can just go ahead and launch a
fleet of agents.
For example, one agent per hyperparameter
combination. This is then a grid search
in hyperparameter optimization.
You spin them up, you run your EAs, you
tear them down again, super frugal way,
you get your data points, um,
you have tested out all combinations and you
have a solid data
uh base basically,
uh, that you can ground your decision based
on. Then you, then
we move on, um, once we have found
the ideal setup, we push this in the
code versioning, repository,
GitHub, code commit,
whatever you want to use,
this triggers an automated CICD
pipeline that is here for QA and
testing.
It's going to deploy another ephemeral
agent.
Just one agent now. We run our tests,
we get the results. If we are below the bar
that we have set, we go back to the first phase.
But let's assume we are good enough,
then we can deploy into production. Now it's a
persistent agent that we want to use
as back end for our
production application.
And we close the loop by learning
from from what's happening in production.
So this is the infra site.
Now how does that look like on
the tooling site?
And I want to start with uh
recognizing that all of these three phases,
uh, you know, are based on
the concept of that we have traces
available, right? Without the traces, we don't
know what's going on in the agents.
We basically need them. This is kind of the,
the core assumption we are building the
rest upon.
Now, the first two phases are actually
pretty similar in a way.
We are running experiments
of different sizes.
Uh, based on mainly offline evals with
data sets that we have configured, the main difference
is we might want to use different eAs
because we want to test other
things in those spaces,
and then the size of the data sets can vary.
If you think about it,
in the first step you have a fleet of agents. If you
use a huge data set, it gets
expensive.
Now in the second step, you have only one agent
to test on, so you can maybe with the same
budget.
You know, do,
do some more testing cycles, but this is really a trade-off
we need
to think through.
And then in the second phase,
we are basically um you know transitioning,
transitioning a bit more into
an online way of doing eAs, even though
I think offline eWs is also
possible,
and we use uh or
we might want to use a cool feature in length
use, the annotation feature where we can
actually have humans annotate traces
and feed them back into our data sets.
So to bring it all together, uh, we have
talked about uh how to actually evolve
DevOps into something
we might wanna call agent ops, uh, satisfying
your requirements that have been popping up,
um, with
powerful services like Agent Core
that are integrating, uh, with
third party, um,
you know, uh, observability agents,
uh, tooling platforms out there,
um, and we are really flexible because
they integrate, uh, well.
And we've also spoken about, you
know, kind of a new culture with new processes
that we are proposing here and we
hope you will all embrace, um, uh,
in order, um, you know, to have uh a new
era of,
uh, successful software engineering
now here, um, uh in uh the Agentic
space. Now, before
I, I close it up and hand over to Keith, uh,
I want to point out that
we have a couple of resources for you.
We have actually really built that. Um, there
is a code repository that you can
fork and use as a starting point,
uh, within your orc. There's gonna be some things
that will be different to your orcs,
but I think it's a pretty good starting point.
And then if you wanna dive deeper than what I
could do now in 20 minutes, uh, you might wanna
check out the YouTube video here on the
right side. It's a deep dive
that I've recorded with the CEO of Langfuse
a couple of weeks ago.
And with that I wanna hand over to
Keith who is uh VP engineering at Kuher
Health and um he's leveraging
a lot of the things that we have spoken
about today
uh with uh his teams and in their
day to day work.
Thanks, thanks Earth.
So, uh, at Cohere recently had the
opportunity to, uh, partner with,
uh, the AWS team on the, the beta
and launch for Asian Core.
Uh, and we built on top of it what we call,
uh, Review resolve, which is,
uh, a product that we're using to
help, uh, drive, uh,
improved prior authorization, uh,
prior, prior authorization processes.
So
For those of you who aren't familiar with prior authorization,
um,
in the US healthcare system, it's common practice
where
prior to, uh, uh, a clinician
performing a procedure,
they need to make a request to a health insurance company,
uh,
to get, to get that procedure approved.
And the determination about whether or not that procedure
can be approved is dependent
on a policy.
That policy
can be defined by the insurance company. You have
state level policies, you have federal policies.
In those policies in those policies,
you've got uh medical necessity guidelines
that have to be met uh prior to
uh a a procedure being approved.
So for example, uh, you might
have a knee injury, you're talking with your doctor,
and she recommends that you get surgery
for, uh, uh, for your knee.
Prior to performing surgery, she would have
to submit a prior authorization request
to the healthcare company.
We would take a look at the policy. The
policy might indicate, for example, as one
part of the medical necessity criteria,
you know, prior to, uh, knee surgery,
more conservative therapy has to have been,
uh, uh,
Uh, attempted like physical therapy, for
example, over 2
months before you can get approval for,
uh, for knee surgery.
So that, that, that example is like
sort of a very uh kind of straightforward
one. The reality is that the prior authorization
process, uh, is a very
complex one, in healthcare in
America.
Um,
It has an estimated cost of
about $35 billion annually.
It creates an enormous amount of administrative overhead
for clinicians,
which reduces their time with patients.
Uh, it also affects
the timeliness with the patients get the
appropriate treatment that they need.
So at Cohere, uh, we're really focused
on helping uh clinicians and
patients get to ES faster.
And we do a lot of
uh auto decisioning, so based on the
information that we receive in a prior authorization
request,
the clinical information that we have about a patient,
uh, and the policy that we're examining,
uh, in some cases we can get up to 85%
auto approval rates.
However, in that 15%, uh,
it needs to go to a clinic to a clinician
for review.
Uh, we don't use machine learning, uh,
or AI to ever,
uh, deny deny deny a claim
or deny a prior authorization request.
But what we do use, uh, AI and
agents is to help surface,
uh, clinical information in that,
uh, review, in that review process.
For the clinician to help them figure out
uh whether or not medical necessity guidelines
are being met and that procedure can be approved
or not.
This results in an
uptick in like 30 to 40% faster
reviews uh for uh clinicians,
doctors and nurses who are interacting with
our review tools,
uh, to
make a determination on prior authorization cases.
So I'm gonna talk a little bit just about like the problem
space here, uh, and some of the issues
that we're solving with agents.
Uh, so I think,
you know, typically if you're working, uh, with agents
or language models, you're doing some
sort of
optimization between like latency
cost and
some accuracy measure.
Uh,
in this case for us, uh, latency and
cost aren't the primary factors, uh,
precision and accuracy are paramount.
We're making decisions that, uh,
our, our clinicians are making decisions that determine
whether or not a patient gets the appropriate care.
We're looking through potentially,
you know, huge amounts of data,
uh, for very precise, uh,
uh, information.
The language here, uh, is like
complex and specialized. Frontier languages, uh, frontier
models, state of the art models, uh, do a
reasonably good job
of, uh, picking up on some of this.
Uh, but there are like some, some complex problems
here, so,
uh,
Like lower back pain as an example.
Uh, that might be expressed as lower back
pain, low back pain, pain in the lower back,
uh, LBP, and
You know, everyone who's worked with language models or NLP
is thinking like, well, you know, that's,
you know, that's a problem that's, you know, fairly easily
solved,
uh, to, you know, to sort of semantically
group those.
Uh, the problem though is that,
uh,
In order for you to, uh,
to do that in a way that's effective,
it needs to use like the same ontology
and taxonomy
that the policy is using, right? So
term normalization, concept resolution,
uh, match up to the language and the policy.
Or you're taking the policy and your clinical
information, and a third ontology
and mapping, uh, and taxonomy and mapping
everything to that.
So this is a very, uh,
complex space where, uh, just out
of the box language models aren't able to handle,
uh, uh, a number of these problems.
Uh, agent management is also complex,
so we're dealing with both, um,
structured and unstructured data.
So structured data might be, uh, claims history,
for example,
uh, unstructured data could be, uh,
you know, clinical records.
There can be an enormous amount, uh, of either of
those two.
And I think that if you've done a lot of work with
language models at this point, um,
I think sort of intuitively like
based on, you know, precision and accuracy,
uh,
You can sort of see that something like uh traditional
like uh
uh vector rag search, uh, similarity
search isn't gonna be particularly useful here.
There, there are some times when it sometimes
when it is useful, but you're not looking for something
similar, you're looking for something that like is a
a very precise match.
So we need to do a lot of in context,
uh, learning with our models. So passing
the structure and the structured data in.
We also need different representations of the data.
So, you know,
combining the structured unstructured data into,
say, uh, a graph representation,
uh, you know, and
giving the agent
options for, you know,
uh, how it might want to,
uh, you know, fetch that data to reason
over, uh, is, is critical.
There's also like an important like temporal component
here. So, you know, I mentioned previously
for the knee surgery, conservative therapy,
you need to look at potentially clinical
data or or claims
uh to see if, you know, hey, over the last two months,
has a patient undergone uh
uh physical therapy.
Uh, you might be looking at blood values over time,
you might be looking at very specific, very
specific dosing information over a time window.
Uh, and that kind of temporal data,
uh, retrieval is something that language models typically
don't handle very well.
There's also like a, a context window management problem
here. Uh, you can easily overflow,
uh, uh, a context window with
claims and, uh,
uh, clinical data.
So how do you narrow down what it is you're looking
for, what kind of heuristics can you use to,
uh, determine, you know, what you pass to the model in
con in context.
And then,
you know, the scope of your evaluations here
expands rapidly. Um,
you're dealing with different data representations, you're dealing
with a lot of data,
you need a lot of, uh, you know, ground
truth data to, uh, run your evals against.
This is a very, uh, uh,
you know, the, the complexity here grows rapidly.
So I did want to talk, obviously
this is an Asian core session, like why we're using Asian
core. So,
uh, as you know, sure and Iris
have talked about, you know, bring your own tooling is
a sort of a key principle here.
We were already in like the Lang graph and Lang
fuse, uh, sorry, Lang graph and Lang chain,
uh, ecosystem.
Uh, so we were able to, you know, fairly quickly,
uh, move out of uh
ECS into Asian core.
Uh, we're,
uh, we're using AIS, uh,
for telemetry, for, uh, observability.
Uh
Uh, Iris was just talking about Lang fuse, which
is great. Uh, Arise has,
uh, an open source product called Phoenix, which is
also great.
We do use Arise's Enterprise, uh,
edition, uh, Arise DX,
uh,
but it's, it's a great, their open source Phoenix is a
great point of comparison against, uh,
uh,
uh, Langfuse.
Uh, and we also use light LLM for,
uh, an LLM gateway. I'm not sure how many people
here are using LLM gateways,
uh, and I'll talk about it a little
bit on the next slide.
And then, you know, something that really appeals to us as a startup
is, you know, the minimal, which is
no infrastructure management here.
Uh, and anytime my team's not managing
hardware or infrastructure, they're focused on product
development. We're in a regulated
industry, the, uh, micro VM
architecture, you know, fast spin up spin down,
no red memory is important for us.
Uh,
Trey has brought up the CLI that fits really neatly
into our existing CICD pipelines,
and Otel works really well, like
I said, uh, to hydrate, uh,
Arise.
All of this works like pretty seamlessly out of the box
with minimal code changes.
Two things that are really important for us, uh,
is agent core gateway and governance
and security, and they're, I see them as very tied
together. Uh,
let's say that we have, uh, a specialized subagent
that is, uh,
uh, a claims related subagent, so it's able
to, you know, pull claims for a patient
and, uh,
uh, search for data and and claim history.
Um, and we might have an API that
we have internally that allows you,
has different endpoints to interact with claim
information. What's,
what's nice is we can put agent code gateway in front of it, but
what's critical is that from like not just a security
by design perspective, but compliance
by design.
We need to know, OK, like who's interacting
with the main agent in a review session.
If there's a call to a sub-agent
to look at claims data,
what's the identity of that user who made that
claim, who made that call to the subagent?
What are they authorized to see, and can we
ensure that they only retrieve information for
a patient that they have access to?
This is critical for compliance and,
uh, compliance and audit.
Uh, Stras also mentioned, um,
uh, short and long term memory.
Uh, so short term memory supports,
uh, text and binary data.
Uh, uh, he mentioned Lagraph checkpointing
which needs to use, uh, binary data,
it's very straightforward plug-in from the AWS team
to drop into,
uh, La graph to, uh,
uh, get short term memory storage.
Long term memory, uh, is more complicated,
I think, regardless of the framework you're using.
Um, one thing that we found useful is name
spaces for managing, uh,
like a multi-tenant environment.
Uh,
you need to spend some time thinking about your memory architecture
here. This is, uh, I'd say
significantly more complex than, uh,
uh, short term memory, especially if you have multiple agents.
So I'm gonna just talk about our architecture
a bit here and it, it is, uh, yeah,
I wish I had a, a pointer.
Um,
uh, it looks busy but it's actually like the
complexity of it, uh,
uh, is reduced. I'm only showing one,
agent, uh, which is in the
review all platform and like just in
the middle it shows the uh chatbot
supervisor.
So that's, uh, you know, that's running in line graph,
um,
and we're connecting, uh, to Agent Core
short memory there.
Uh, like I said, very seamless, uh,
integration
within, uh, the chatbot itself is or
this particular agent is running on,
uh, Agent Core infrastructure on the micro
VM.
All of our traffic is running through Light
LLM, uh, to Bedrock.
So Light LLM is an AI gateway.
Uh, if you haven't worked with one of these, it functions
as sort of, uh, like a reverse
proxy for,
uh, talking to different, uh, model providers.
Uh, it gives you really nice features like,
uh, uh, rate limiting,
uh, insight onto like token usage by user,
uh, cost controls, you can put common
guard rails in place.
We're mostly working with Bedrock, but it's
seamless for us to pull in Gemini,
anything from OpenAI,
uh, behind Light LLM,
and if a client in front of Light LLM
wants to use those,
you're really just changing an API key in the
name of a model. Uh, all the other,
uh, work is being handled via, via the gateway.
You can see on the left, we're using uh Arise
uh prompt management.
So So.
I'll talk about emails, uh, in a minute,
um.
For us, uh,
we, we tend to separate our prompts
from, uh, like our application codes
so that we have a life cycle and a deployment
life cycle, a life cycle
A life cycle and a deployment life cycle for
prompts that separate from code.
You can make updates to prompts without having to redeploy,
uh, redeploy containers.
Um, at the bottom you can see, uh,
indication level,
uh, LLM prompt in the lower left there.
So, thinking about that claims
agent for a moment,
uh, you might have this uh
supervisor agent,
and, uh, that's what
the, the, the doctor or the nurse is interacting
with. And you might make a
call to a specialized sub-agent for
claims.
Something that I feel like we, we talk about a lot when we're
talking about MCP is, uh, is tools.
I think how we use prompts
in MCP is really interesting.
I don't see it like as much about it, maybe I'm
reading the wrong, uh, the wrong authors.
But in this case, you know, you could pass
the uh medical necessity criteria
uh to that claims agent.
It could decide what, uh,
you know, claim history it wants to grab, and also
select what is the
medical necessity criteria or the indication
level is the terminology we'd use.
What prompt do I wanna grab,
uh, in order to, uh, look for this
information, uh, in, in the claim history.
Um,
this is a, so there's multiple ways we handle,
uh, clinical data extraction including like with,
uh, fine-tuned models.
Uh, but this is like particularly interesting,
and it's also adds to the complexity
of your evals.
Uh,
it's a powerful methodology, but
as your clinical areas grow, as the number of
prompts you have grow,
Um,
being able to, you know, evaluate whether or
not you retrieved the right prompt and applied
it in the right way for that subagent against that
data to get the information you're looking for
becomes another set of evaluations
you have to run.
Uh,
the announcement of session level evals, uh, is
really exciting,
being able to run evals across, like,
you know, the whole, uh, the whole set of agentic
interactions, uh, is, is really
critical.
And then, uh, I'm just gonna touch on,
uh, evals here briefly. Uh,
it's my, my slide here is much busier than
Iris's.
So like I mentioned, uh, earlier, we're
already in, uh, the Arise ecosystem.
Uh,
we have online evals, so
you know, from, uh, from
Lang Langgraph and Agent Core, we have data going
into Arise.
Uh, that can get piped into our
online e e evaluation. We could
have a L as a judge there,
looking at things like ha hallucination rate,
uh,
we could be looking at guideline, uh, guardrail
violations, there's like a number of things that you
might wanna, uh, be looking at for,
uh, online evals.
And especially like if you wanted to determine
if, you know, performance is changing in any way.
Uh, we also hook into our offline
evals here. Um, so,
uh, we are, we have clinicians on
staff, doctors, nurses,
subject matter experts,
so we're able to, uh, have, uh,
human annotators, uh, in the loop here,
uh, and that can all be fed into
our, uh, offline, uh,
uh,
evals process where we're, you know, uh,
You know, determining the the effectiveness
of a particular prompt, of a fine-tuned,
uh, small language model,
uh, of the agentic system
or the set of agentic calls, uh,
as a whole.
Uh, and just like with Langfuse,
like we already had something like this,
we're able to
keep this mostly working as is, uh,
and, uh, plug it into Asian core,
uh, and get all this data hydrated the way that we
needed it to.
Um
That's uh, that's uh it for me. I'm gonna hand it back
to Shreyas.
Thank you Keith and uh
uh you know in summary what we saw
is we saw Asian core uh that
can integrate with multiple open source uh
uh frameworks as well as protocols.
uh Aris walked us through Asian tops
as well as uh a deeper integration
with Lang fuse and we saw a really exciting
real world uh application with, uh,
coherent Health as well.
I'm gonna leave this slide up there for, for,
uh, for you to scan. I know folks
are trying to hurry up and scan quickly when
we change. So thank you so much for
attending our session and I hope
you found this informative.
Uh, we're gonna hang out here, uh, for
a little bit to take any questions later on.
Thank you so much.